[Music]
[Music]
hello and welcome to the st. Louis
Archbishop's first playoff match in the
protest League of course we qualified
straight to the quarterfinals thanks to
our regular season performance and today
we will actually be squaring off against
the Indian Yogi's but why don't we take
a look in see oh yeah of course my name
is Caleb Denby and I'm joined by the
wonderful vara Cobian will be I think
we're gonna look at the standings first
see where everyone in the league sits of
course it's the st. Louis Archbishop's
had an astounding regular season
finishing with the most points in the
entire league as well as I believe the
highest performance rating in the entire
league so definitely we're gonna be the
team to beat in this playoff season we
escort first place in the Western
Division and today you'll see we face
the India Yogi's from the Eastern
Division who placed third in their
division so definitely not you know not
not a pushover team by any means though
great yeah yeah but why don't we
actually take a look at where these
teams from the regular season now sit in
the playoff bracket of course we already
have seen the the round of 8 or the
round of however many that is because of
course it got a little bit strange with
you know the first-place team each
division getting the skip around in the
playoffs and we saw the Canada chess
bras and the Chicago wind both win their
first playoff match so those two teams
of course from the Western Division as
well and then we saw the New York
Marshalls actually defeat the France
Roosters to advance as well and so what
we see here is 14 yeah of course they
had the better regular-season
performance so they got to advance so
what we've seen how in the quarterfinals
is actually four teams from the Western
Division that is our division have
already advanced and still be
interesting to see I guess we can't get
the the perfect western division in
Norway
but we can get three out of four yeah of
course the China pandas formerly the
chengdu pandas one of our biggest rivals
to look out for for sure and then of
course today we have the st. Louis
archbishop squaring off against the
India Yogi's and they won their match
against Norway 9 to 7 yeah so definitely
a strong team they have a shock they are
mama Dee out of shock mom and yard party
tell Hari Krishna yeah we're gonna
actually pull up the pairings I don't
know do we have them well I can just
read us our lineup first of all oh here
we go
so of course we have Fabiano kara wanna
playing board one for us
Lennie a dominguez board to Westley so I
believe is board three and then Jeffrey
Zhang is our board four and then
conversely for the India yogi so you
have shocked mom and yaar of world class
player if not from India but he is their
one free agent free agent yeah
and then of course there are other
Krishna is the second highest ranked
player about 2750 yeah India India stars
he's number two and then we have
dangerous Audubon I mean he's about
twenty six sixty eighty by the very very
dangerous players yeah well within the
top 100 if he has a good day then he
could be and then they have not I am
there's another 2600 Grandmaster I mean
definitely we're gonna try to score a
lot of points and abort six that's what
we going to do yeah I mean correct me if
I'm wrong but I think Hari Krishna is
actually the highest rated player in
India aside from of course Vishy Anand
you know tough to beat Vichy but a hardy
Krishna a world-class player and has
been for some time now so of course
however judging from the lineup
we are favored in almost every match
every except for against shock mom in
Europe shock is actually hard and
venerated
then then our bottom three boards for
the moment according to the pairings
here but oh yeah yeah yeah shock you
know his ratings up there these days
of course this is our star lineup we
have
freeze young grandmaster Fabiana
karamaneh Lenny a Dominguez and Wesley
so we have another very top 2,700 player
just we cannot fit all of them we have
also very strong blitz specialist laQuan
Liam yes
very very strong player and but again we
can you can only put for 2,700 if your
five boards but with have more advantage
of course and then here we have the
format for the protest League a few
changes from last year actually the time
controls are now ten it's ten minutes
with a two second increment that's down
from 15 minutes last year you get 10
points for winning a match and then
that's added on to your match score as
your total score for the match of course
now that this is the playoffs all that
matters is winning the match and we do
actually have draw odds in this match
thanks to our regular season performance
24 teams were in the regular season and
now we are down to just eight I believe
yeah essentially doing really well in
the regular season gave us by in the
first round of the playoffs and also
gives us a basically half a half point
advantage in this match is because
anytime we tie we're gonna advance and
don't happen previously with trial with
Webster team yeah we're a tough match
and you know we tie with them and we
advance well I think the games are
actually getting underway so maybe we
can check them out and start out with
the Fabiano's game I think we also still
need to follow Jeffery I think he logged
on a little bit late oh good we can find
him here so yeah so slash follow ok I
got I got [ __ ] we'll just click over
here ok and we'll find the game well
actually only three games are in
progress so far
ok maybe Jeffrey's game hasn't started
yet ok let's just jump into the chest
alright so this is again we have again
big advantage we have on this board we
have Fabiano Caruana
with block against
no Narayana the the fourth port and so
of course in the first round your board
one plays the the other board will block
and again it's not easy for 2800 to just
just go out there and be the 2600 block
it's not so we see some sloth defense
here and Fabiana is trying to keep as
many pieces on the board as possible but
I gotta tell you Caleb it's very solid
position it's not gonna be easy to crack
this position for block because and
Fabiano needs to build sometime but not
so easy I mean good opening choice by
not I am yeah white doesn't really seem
to make too many we should be passive on
c8 as well I don't know so that's
probably why b6 was played yeah let me
see extra bleep there should be seven
yes dude maybe even something like 94 in
Bishop a 6-2 yes yes so again
Fabiano it just he's very very strong
where things get complicated in
complications we always see that you
know he can out calculate his opponent
that's it's definite well one of the
major strengths he has over his opponent
that he can calculate really really well
yeah and quickly as well exactly this is
only 10 minutes so bounce you down get
down on the clock you basically you're
gonna have to move on instincts yes and
you know we see that he always tries to
be a head on a clock put pressure on his
opponents so I'm curious sir if white
were to take on d5 but black capture
with the epon yeah you must capture with
the e pawn because if you capture with
the C fund then you're gonna give this B
5 squared yes in fact you're gonna lose
the exchange Bishop b5 will win a the
rook on the 8 so if capture occur
Fabiana is gonna take back with the e
pawn for sure and then he's gonna
probably prepare the c5 break at some
point like I mentioned maybe put the
knight on before yeah and then play
finally play the move c5 it seems like
like does have some ideas here yeah yeah
it's it's not so clear even what Y
should do y should play maybe a for
Bishop f3 or maybe you should play
Bishop f3 by the way f4 it's always like
weakens your position so it's a little
bit of a commitment so I don't know if
that's exactly what he should do so he
decided to capture okay but this I think
is okay for buck because now it opens up
the room
hurricane breeze so be 97 not I am is
trying to play be forth he's trying to
prepare the before break here I'm not so
sure that's it's a huge threat I think
like would be happy to take on before
and put a file yeah oh by the way but
also Caleb did upon is under attack
so it's a little bit more concrete he's
attacking it but what about the move c5
I'm wondering if I'll be on a place c5
here you cannot capture the the knight
is hanging right so this should be 596
rookie sex immediately six-foot I like
that move it makes a lot of sense f4 and
I guess she can play c5 now or maybe
ninety-four percent this is this is kind
of hidden up here we see some potential
f5 coming up as well here both players
spend about two minutes at the moment
yeah f4 really gives away this in
Foursquare so I like a Fabi just jumping
in there right away also you saw the
movie you know Knight a two and usually
when a knight moves away from the center
like you want to take advantage of it
absolutely absolutely
Knight move on a 294 comes in taking
advantage of the Knights
passive retreat and now you know at some
point if six is coming up the question
is why can't play Bishop g4 here to try
to induce a five and then retreat then
that way Knight can be secured so I
would consider that actually I will
consider Bishop g4 f5 at something like
Bishop f3 here that way at least I know
my knight only five is gonna be secured
at submission that's what he does it's
played no other choice I think yeah no
other choice because the docks were
Bishop is guarding a lot of scores as
well so maybe black can can finally
break through with c5 after that's why
he goes well I think c5 is still
playable because you gain the tempo with
the rook on f1 you capture any
or anything yeah yeah it's it's really
really interesting because c5 the only
thing is white me play Knight c3 back
and try to put a knight on d5 okay that
might be an idea but then we can put our
own icon before so yeah it looks
double-edged and so Bishop takes e5 I
was actually thinking about this move
but I thought after F takes the the
structure was was pretty solid for white
and even g4 ideas good comment yeah I'm
not sure this is this is a big decision
by Fabiano's and these kind of surprises
me actually obviously if you take back
with deep on then black will play c5 is
very happy but this position I don't
know it's it looks looks g4 threats I
think for for white there's some g4 at
some point 93 is a very logical choice
here needs to be considered yes no no I
hopefully Fabiano has a good plan here
because the decision he made is well
maybe he's simply trying to play
something like Queen g5 Queen she's Papa
now I'm thinking about Luca for maybe
yeah we're cat for or rook f3 maybe even
Knight c7 coming into e6 uh-huh that's
what he wants to do okay and then
probably white should play Knight c3
trying to trade that night off the board
yeah that's that's fair enough but I'm
not so sure there's all these things
like c5 and his Knight takes e4 the the
worst thing ever maybe I'll take back
with the D pawn actually no well then
sorry bishop ii well if I play 97 and
then take that deep on May 25 is plate
put this knight on d5 96 night is coming
to e6 just as we predicted it so nicely
3 trying to trade a strong night off the
board so you might even take this night
with black I think just to prevent any
change to your structure except anything
like when you're opening up in position
okay because yeah if 94 is play do you
take with a pawn that Bishop c4 is
unpleasant yeah if take with so yeah
Fabi does capture and then I'm expecting
like Rick e8 here just get this night to
e6
their controls that for continued to
play the six looks so strong Caleb the
bishop on d6 ah fair enough but I don't
know I like this night it keeps
everything together it keeps everything
solid and then eventually I think blacks
gonna play
for to break to break things open then
they only six actually eyes a weakness
on Dino night the only six absolutely
it's a fantastical place night it's a
very well placed I do think that Bishop
on this six is gonna cause a lot of
problems because it yes
takes the f8 square takes the beef be
eight squared I would play Bishop d6
here without any hesitation ninety-six I
will just drop the route back to f2 or
some yeah something like that
luckily for white the rook on c3 is
already doing a great job with Texas
yeah I think blacks other problem here
is actually this LightSquared bishop
yeah that's that's kind of problem you
have to yeah and you're a little bit
tied up to c6 because you can't just
play [ __ ] basics to get rid of it so it
could be some preparatory work needs to
be done and maybe the c5 see is what
needs to come Oh Steve I move
maybe after rook c8 as well just to keep
everything so we got Jeffrey is playing
us well we got yes you can click that
and then we can follow him all right so
let's take a look at so we can look at
since we're on this game we can look at
this so this is Jeffrey playing against
mama D out of here so Jeff if they D for
opted for more solid setup so we have oh
I don't know what that is watchin yeah
we're good we're moving on so we have
like a very solid position for Jeffrey
so he's you know aiming to play some
really position it's a good strategy
shock as a dangerous player yes so I
think even a drawing this matchup it
favors us I would definitely agree so
you see kind of the one open file in the
center of the board usually kind of
signifies major pieces are gonna get
traded off yeah and probably play f3
here yeah just solidify every Bishop f2
if needed Oh Bush pays six straight
alive score bishops yeah so I would
really considered that sound like I like
Jeff is position I think he's at least
you know if not slightly better is just
very very solid yeah I don't like it for
trying to win but we don't need to beat
Shaq mom in you are okay
absolutely absolutely let's take a look
at other matchups here I see there's
some disadvantage we have on this board
here is like King on f5 like it what's
going on here this is the game oh wait
sorry I like this I was gonna say I
looks like this King really just got to
see wherever so it was a French defense
opening that I know a little bit I
played for a long time so French defense
we have the rubenstein violation but
yeah Geoffrey West is very strong in
this position so I actually placed him a
few times it didn't go quite well for me
so this is all theory so well yeah white
kind of gains control over every light
square I know before he wants to play
Bishop a5 attacking the Queen Queen c8
it's a red I guess if you play b6 bishop
drops back to c3 if B 6 I think you can
oh yeah and then a is saying wow oh but
this is something went wrong before Hari
Krishna this looks oh wow d5 there's
something went wrong here
yeah I'm willing to bet you miss d5 in
respond steps yes this cannot be right
this is just alright
yeah now it is an endgame so the black
King probably isn't gonna get checkmated
Spanish I mean the white pieces are just
way too that this is just lost and you
know great start by Vesely here
completely getting a crushing position
against Hari Krishna yeah what is coming
up actually I think it's been performing
the best out of all the Archbishop's on
the roster this year and I think a f4 is
threatening now at five yeah and if the
King drops back to f7 and then Reese
over 57 King g8 and then the the
reputation I think notice that none of
the black pieces can develop the rook he
can't develop the bishop and all the way
pieces this is great this is great this
was great so let's take a look now we
have linear Domingues against a deep on
walking with Linea he gets down to the
clock you know yeah Lenny a he likes to
take his time that's what we have
noticed in his game but he plays
tremendously well under time pressure
ya know I remember seeing him at the
first rapid and blitz that he played you
know he's
he's got two seconds on the clock and he
plays the whole professional just so
this is we have a catalan here against
against strong audubon they call him the
Beast the Beast yeah so and it's kind of
a standard staff here 95 this I think
that this all played before they should
be q the reason you can play night for
you think you've captured you can take
back with a pawn and say for this hand
on the c-4 ball great I now would be
four square I always like putting this
night on this be four squares so you
cannot capture because pawn will take
back and then c3 is hanging so the
question is what is the what is Adi bung
gonna do it because next is we're gonna
capture an attacker yeah this is sweet
maybe this was just another mister move
it looks like things are kind of falling
apart for the Indian Yogi's early on
here especially on well on these two
bracelets so this two ports yeah I think
we see a clear advantage for archbishops
for our team
yes so tactically you know you cannot
capture on d5 due to how many pieces
White has hanging and you can't move the
night away because then he takes a four
hits the Queen and then you can simply
win I think two pawns which is fine you
take take on a fourth yeah you take on I
guess he's gonna go clean b2 and just
try to play down upon but yeah maybe
there's even Queen B 2 a 3 a 3 and Queen
takes way of 92 and yeah okay Rick takes
maybe a tank and yeah that and then 93
this is definitely I mean this
definitely went wrong for audubon here
and linear Domingues is taking taking
over the game here for sure I think it
was really nasty move yeah I think I
might just win exchange
but then I mean what else do we need
five oh he made a threat so he perhaps
g6 is safe enough yeah he he's attacking
f7 so so g6 is going to grow what Queen
f3
well I I imagine so but maybe at the end
of the day we just take e5 and play
Queen c7 and then we can take that pawn
on e5 off the board I'm thinking about
actually taking only five pawn takes and
potentially we're sacrificing the coin
you have the Queen I even Aging's yeah
take sticks because we have nice c2
coming up 92 I mean that's a lot it's a
lot I don't know if we see minutes on
the clock yeah but but I mean it's
definitely with these pawns you can just
play g6 get up just six Queen f3 right
yeah just take only 5 a 2500 Queen c7 I
mean the e5 is hanging yeah that's
that's actually 292 is breaking hers
Wesley has actually converted his his
game as we expected the case comes out
to g4 it's just a fantastic game here
that's the first win for the
archbishop's I think something we missed
at the top of the show is predictions oh
I think you were saying came to 10 6 my
my prediction for of course archbishops
yeah that's my I think you know so you
think we're gonna go +1 in every round
basically on average plus 1 plus 2 I
think it sounded they're gonna try to
put up a good fight but I think we just
just it's just too very strong yeah I
think it strong I think he can
definitely expect I think two and a half
points from shock on the indie a Yogi's
and so that's that's gonna be I think
where they need to score their points so
why don't we see what what shock is
doing again they got this position I
like what Geoffrey is doing is just
completely neutralizing shock here and
Shaq is slightly worse they know yes
anybody Geoffrey get this night on each
area is actually really well placed
yeah knight on f6 miss played there's a
little loose in that's there to c6 is
little Lucy v is loose vicious and g7
yeah they're gonna be a draw here but
that's that's fine
you know we'll take a draw you know
in our boards for against their board
one absolutely controlling this matchup
so what I want to see I want to see
really quickly what's going on in the
Fabiano's game because this is the one
I'm a bit concerned was bit concerned
earlier so let's just see where we left
off here this night was about to reach
is six so it was played expected that so
Bishop every Queen h4 now there's some
pressure on d5 to look out for yeah so
now g3 should treat you now Fabiano is
still pushing and one stage for Queen g3
the Queen's come off the board please
come off the board and now before is so
while b5 well I think Bobby is kind of
scrambling for he's you know he's still
trying to maybe look for the win but
it's difficult before I think he's just
trying to kind of hold hold on at this
point yet for sure h 496 interesting
he's not rip f1 here interesting he's
not driving worried about bishop f1 here
fish perform and if you cannot take the
sixes hanging that looks slightly
problematic
maybe okay so he just found his own
tactic yeah I think we play yeah Bishop
f1 I thought probably might be relying
on Rick h8 there just just take the H
pawn and then everything kind of
liquidates
yeah I don't know still very unpleasant
King f2 yeah if you take the knight take
on b5 and right I mean at the pen so
basically white one a palm here but Mike
wins a pawn here but I think upon an h4
it is an H for the night only six is
very strong so we expect Bobby to make a
draw here yes hopefully which you know
from our board one against their board
for is an ideal but from the position I
think the key is not to lose maybe rook
c4 I think is already just picking up
before Bishop c5 then the n96
96 something like that there's still you
know it's not that easy yet but it's
still I think you just have to really
keep an eye on this 'if I've pun as a
way to Vega important important to get
that h4 pond I like this movement keeps
the king out announcer mom yes no no
made me rick d3 rather than Erick
seafloor and you're just still putting
pressure on the pawns and you're not
allowing the King state if you're taking
h6 Bishop effaith King h5 yeah I don't
think you want to push the black king up
the board here so yeah not the easiest
endgame or for either side I think but
okay yeah no is building some time
advantage so she'll be up closer to
quickly look at to see how
Domingues game developed here so after
night they try to decided not to play so
six and just take right away I mean I
would have liked to see g6 first I think
I think yeah the worst Square is
misplaced on f3 yeah I would have liked
to see that as well actually so but
hypocrisy 794 by Audubon c5 I guess
there's a bishop b6 here so you can
update night to see two right away so
you played c5 now threatening 92 93 and
so we see some liquidation coming off
the board now
so yeah so we see some liquidations here
looks like both let's have about a
minute each
that's about equal here I don't see any
problems here for lanius so here maybe
the money I should've should have had
more in this game I think so I think
this this this moment she's six Sims
feels like she's six maybe pushing him
back yeah I didn't what a weekend they
have six squared perhaps but I don't
think there was a big issue
yeah I mean not only five coming off the
board anyways yeah there's no way Knight
is reaching f6 you know so and here
perhaps he was counting on night C -
maybe but there's a bit should be six
alright so let's see what's submission
pay for Knight g4 and yeah I don't
actually hate the night in this end game
there's still is this one pawn on the
Queen side but black spawn is on a dark
square and so the white bishop will be
in a more defensive role
yeah well the key in this position is to
try to of course win the a pawn yeah a
for bonus week so I think he's gonna try
to play maybe well if you play 94 then
there's the rook c3 so maybe you were
thinking f2 yeah and the 94th and maybe
a check on the eight q7 r OC 8 so I
think their worst case you could even
play Knight B - I think and you can just
if vertex a five-burner k1 and I think
you get the pot yeah I mean block is
very solid here and he's oh I would
think black is the only one who can I
mean one thing you want to avoid this
trading rooks yeah and the trade routes
and give the key the corridor then yeah
but pure minor P Sunday no I would just
play here I like pinky seven nice keep
the servitor kind of the game
I like that so just and then if Rick b3
I can actually play Rick beats
that was really nice cuz it guards the
88 square yeah so there's no rook da to
maneuver you know so now uh notably
they're down to their final seconds here
white must find some way to defend this
this a pond he doesn't he just allows
well hold on can you just play King is
maybe juice six you know kinky kinky
eight what's stopping the King from
going to d7 though he did that he did
that and say King d7 here I think indeed
is shelling the jaw oh you just accept
the drop perhaps King the seventy will
go to Cafe donkeys okay eight and then a
rook c5 a desk well I think it draws
draw response only that's what we have
to look at Fabiano scheme so Fabi is now
finding himself down upon in a wreck
endgame but I don't think there's any
way black is actually losing this no
decision I think in fact Pike is trying
to win yeah I don't know if it's the
best idea to try to win this position
but I don't think that we can yes even
take the d4 pawn their III is is
guarding this upon justice looks like
just got to make sure Geoffrey holds you
know yeah you know maybe wins so Rick
III I think is pretty much unstoppable
here for Bobby I'm gonna catch this keep
on stop it in its tracks
yeah it should be a draw white is still
thinking I guess is considering from
graph three or something yeah well look
f3 will be met by even rookie aids I
think Rick f4 check is is kind of a
funny winning try cuz King e5 I think is
a losing media in that case yeah okay
draw is occurred and now we just have
one game remaining so let's see here
what do we got here what do we have here
looks like Geoffrey and as we were
expecting is the only one who could
press here just a nice quick if you just
trick mommy down off
no just midnight at 5:00 this is where
is from yeah no I didn't quite realize
at first but Jeffers winning the pair of
Bishops that looks like yeah at least
winning the pair of the bishops if you
take on F 296 wins apiece if you take
with the Bishop Bishop c5 that's a real
really troublesome then everything is
gonna be hanging if you take with Knight
f5 just Bishop takes f5 yeah this is
really bad yeah b6 coming takes I think
we're I think Jeffrey's just winning so
maybe Jacques has to actually play
Bishop takes a5 Bishop takes d5 in the
97 Bishop e7 Bishop e7 pick up the g5
pawn yeah well I guess we should have 78
Bishop e6 maybe we should be 6o gavel
trade only six mhm I don't even have to
oh wow so I missed this move entirely
differently this is just right now
Knight age six picks up they have seven
pump that he's gonna take one of to play
95 yeah Bishop Bishop c4 c4 and then
bully by the ng fiber then he goes king
of six yeah maybe it needs to play like
Bishop g3 yeah it's a nice movie three
takes okay now the question is I think G
takes makes more logical sense to me
okay
he's gonna go Bishop d6 trying to put a
knight on c5 yeah hmm so I mean with the
two bishops Oh Geoffrey should be doing
quite well
yeah there's no there's no any risk for
him and the opposition just the question
is we felt like maybe he was so it's
amazing this night b7 was a very clever
defendant so he takes the eponymous you
to interesting okay Bishop c2 prepares
for a 95 yeah there's there's no
entrance for the King which is why I
wanted to take with the cheap on I
thought maybe we can play strategy for
it probably keep stays on g7 and that's
so probably gonna be a draw yeah and
there's yeah I was thinking but I think
blacks just in time to to deal with this
threat yeah probably probably just like
there's 95 in the 97 I think would pick
up the other stuff that's excellent
he wears a pawn but it's just a drug
King stays on c5 yeah it's very
important that King is on c5 because if
King had actually reached b5 then you
have the Seaforth clock nothing to be
done now also notably a Fabiano's game
did and draw as the expected so plus one
plus one we get two and a half points
again we magic magic number is eight for
us eight just wins all right so if we
tie the match we're winning so plus one
some chances here for Geoffrey and you
know I think some chances for linear
yeah I thought it was the only one kind
of under pressure
yeah I think maybe missed like you're
right your suggestion of king e7 here I
think it's just such a nice keep the
rock out maybe a big baby
yeah rook b3 I was I was thinking that
like rook me too but I don't think I
don't know in the minor piece endgame
now blacks King is very close to the
center but you have to keep but this
pawn on e5 is restricting okay I think
black was maybe slightly better you know
another idea that now I'm thinking about
maybe with the g5 here
Yeji fine to provoke some weaknesses g5
takes 95 and if not take on a fourth
even f6 could make like a pawn I like
this g5 because we will create a
weakness in fact I for would be weak
like later on we move the knight in a
Brook c4 and things would start Hank -
so I think yeah I mean g5 of course the
problem in the game was the black King
had nowhere to go
yes in fact linea warmed upon but he
really needed to have the Jeep on so he
can pack in his King nicely on g7 here
but he never had the time so he had some
chances here but again it's a good score
we'll take two and a half every match
absolutely magical take twin have to get
to that you know magic number eight that
we need to advance here because we have
a better tie breaks all right well why
don't we we have the pairings for round
two I think we're working on getting it
up in just a moment here so what
happened in this French for Howie
Krishna I don't know I think how he just
didn't know what was going on and I've
tried it a few times I don't it seems
like you're always under pressure one of
my last games against Vesta didn't go
really well in the US Championship so I
I lost like a twenty five moves
interesting in playing dislike stop
playing this there's a finish time it's
just it's just passive a little bit yeah
all of a sudden my first I remember here
Caleb you're supposed to go Knight b6
ish that that would make sense cuz in
the game why can I just took over this
Airport I remember the theories 96 they
take on c5 Bishop c5 before Bishop e7 e
5 c5 sorry
c5 95 piece of 95 there mm-hm
you have to put the Queen on C so
there's a queen a fortune you end up
actually going King f8 that's okay but
you know of course in the game the
bishop is undeveloped ninety of six
might be just the losing move here yeah
it just allows this Queen a for business
or anything ship a5 was a really Ewing
you cannot take because Queen and for
check yeah and won't cancel so it's and
it's just it's over yeah yeah and then
yeah King is just getting made it here
yet f5 keeps the King out and then the
rook
oh it's aw it's so bad no h3 h4 mate
cannot be stopped
yeah this was a wonderful game alright
so off to a good start for it yeah why
don't we pull up the results from round
one and see how it all worked out so of
course the Archbishop's are at two and a
half to the Indian Yogi's one one and a
half that one extra point came from
grandmaster Wesley so in that game we
were just looking at against Pantani
Jeffries on our board for managed to
draw the astounding Shakman yar off
board one for the Indian Yogi's a bead
on has drawn Linea Dominguez and Iranian
has drawn Fabiano Caruana as wow we
could say the bottom boards did well for
India in this match
yeah and actually well the the bottom
boards on both sides did pretty all
right of course I think Wesley is either
I think Wesley's actually our our board
three so believe it or not our board
three upset their board two in the first
round if you can call it upset so the
next the next round I think is will be
critical because yeah you know if we can
score another Plus that will give us a
huge yeah round one kind of sets the
tone but then around to if if you know
that a new Yogi's actually go - in the
first two rounds then I feel like that's
very disheartening it's gonna be very
difficult to come back you know so they
need to at least try to win this match
or tie this match yeah - stay stay stay
yeah I mean the question is always where
are those points going to come from as
we look at my parents
Fabiano white against Adi bond I don't
think they're scoring their points
they're near white again that I am tough
to score points there as well Mahmoud
yellow white against regester biggest
shock
John can have a good day impress and
then Hari Krishna with white against
Jeffrey that's a close match up as well
so I think definitely they get they
hoping this might be the matchups yeah I
think in the Dickens or some points and
maybe they're putting in four can
somehow hold you know I think it's it's
gonna be the classic strategy you know
draw with black and win with white if
they can pull that off and they have a
really solid chance
absolutely and getting back into this is
a huge round this round two is gonna
dictate what's gonna happen here notably
for the archbishop's something I found
it is as we approach the later rounds
that's when you know the top boards plan
top boards and the lower boys club lower
boards that's really when the
Archbishop's excel you know we in this
head-to-head matchup where things are
you know kind of the most even the most
fair that's when the advantage really
wins in our favor so I think these early
rounds are where India needs to be
scoring his points yeah definitely they
have a very strong lineup I'm you
definitely came up with a very very
strong lineup India
absolutely so it's definitely
challenging challenging team here
alright well once again let's take a
look at the playoff and bracket of
course we are in the bottom right with
the India Yogi's playing to advance to
the semi finals of course the winner of
this match goes to Norway the if we win
against the Indian Yogi's the Final Four
will take place sooner or later we know
the results for the China and because I
think they played today right March 9
let's see what we've got
March 9
it looks like the China pandas did
defeat the Germany bears nine and a half
to six and a half so the pandas are in
for the final four pandas are in they
punched their tickets for Oslo nine and
have very strong team yeah definitely
the Germany bears actually won their
division so it's a little bit of an
upset for the junior pandas to defeat
Germany of course they finished fourth
yeah so they just barely qualified for
these playoffs but they're making a good
show of it here defeating the California
unicorns and now the Germany berries as
well Germany very strong players like
your admirer on that team other notable
names and the score was nine and a half
nine and a half to six and a half all is
correct
so pandas are the first team to reach
the the finals yet congratulations to
them unfortunately for them they find
themselves on the same side of the
bracket as us so they will not be seeing
their chances survive for too long I
think all right we're just waiting for
the next round to get underway at this
point yeah we have solid free throws in
this round yeah three draws one win
keeping keeping it safe you think that's
Plus core you know that that's what we
need
yeah in in these matches of course it's
very important not to give up those full
points you know if if you're on board
for and you have like a worse position
it's really important to really like
hold hold the position because giving up
a half points not so bad giving up a
full point that's that's when it becomes
very difficult to get an advantage and
around absolutely we're waiting for the
next the games will start automatically
yeah so why don't we show the good
people how to follow the games for
themselves on chess calm turns out in
the chest calm chat if you click down
where it says message right down here
yeah well right there if you type
forward slash I'll let you do it bar I
trust you / yeah yeah and now follow
follow okay follow just like that space
hashtag can you find the pound sign yeah
difficult PCL piece you know that's the
one broke Chesley Crow chess league now
hit enter hit enter and bam he should be
following everybody you need to be
following Wow alright and so now all the
games will show up automatically you can
do this at home for yourselves make sure
you follow the games that interest you
the most of course will be trying to
keep an eye on all of them as they
happen but you know if you won game
interest you more than others then to
see their round 2 yet coming up we'll be
around to do we have the well I guess
weird looked up there huh yeah why don't
we take a look at the st. Louis
Archbishop's full rosters see who else
we've got of course you know we're
playing four of our top players also
notably our free agent Liam Lee is on
there as well he's done quite well for
us so far in the regular season he
doesn't make his appearance in the
playoffs just yet but perhaps we'll see
more of him later
Benjamin Bach of course a slew student
in the st. Louis area
he's just played one game one round for
us but we've got a solid two points
before in sorrow for all the way down
there one of the strongest
internationals international masters in
the world you know Nicholas Theodore who
has also played for us and they actually
went +1 on board for yeah of course you
also see you know our notable players
from past years Julian Pro Lake oh the
hero of the final four iron last year
Josh bloomer of course another regular
on the Archbishop's and you actually
vote I believe you're on there as well
yeah haven't played yet but yeah well
the team was doing great so we have some
games now games are started so we have
the Metropole Fabiana white against adi
bomb yeah and we see English English I
don't think this is something I've seen
from favi so far in the protest League
this looks like some new stuff from him
so yeah this is a huge game in audubon
you need to really playing his best here
to give his game chances here so a5
Blake yeah I've never really liked these
early Bishop before lines for black they
just feel slightly unnatural
putting this Bishop all away before
losing it
and now white develops the night with
the threat to the e5 phone d6 is played
yeah is six and eight three so Bishop
goes to c5 g3 preparing some of the four
options yeah you see all these Tempe
getting lost against this base a lot a
lot of Tempe first a three hitting the
bishop and now no this pawn will come to
d4 with tempo as well and the bishop
will have to retreat all the way back to
e7 so in preparation for this we see c6
kicking the knight back and you're
simply Knight bTW seven maybe 7d for us
expected no there's some central tension
here but I don't think either player
really wants to break it just yet
probably Bishop e2 disease you're p2
castle okay canceled get everything
developed we should get you a little bit
more aggressive approach by Fabiano yeah
I guess he's not so worried about the
opening of the e-file because this
nighttime g8 isn't yet developed so yeah
now Knight of 6 I think taking on d4
might be a threat so white castles and
the question is will black try to break
through with d5 at some points and how
do you get this Bishop on c8 develop
this is a very common problem piece so
what do we see from Bobby okay let's see
here um the mood that comes to mind is
before actually yeah before but should
be too it's one idea that I think you
can do yeah already let's go for it
I think yeah now's a good time for b4
because the opening of the a file will
be reactor watch out for the e4 so I'm
thinking maybe play Queen sheet 2 now
Bishop c2 instead so trying to provoke
e4 perhaps yeah I was gonna say the
opening to eat the a file would be
really bad for black at this moment cuz
this Bishop on see a kind of cuts the
major pieces in half
you can see proficiency - I wonder if
there was anything wrong with Quincy -
probably I cannot see anything right
away so if if I was played Fabiana wants
to play 90 - I guess yeah like 92 you
can also play a move like f3 once this
pawn lands on e4 and the opening the F
file could be pretty advantageous yeah
so if that's a d5 we should be putting
some pressure on this Abel
threatening now to take on before us
well I like the move b5 for Fabi here I
think b5 gives a lot of space the only
thing would be farmers I'm just thinking
maybe a forest plate tonight for 92 I'm
worried about this Bishop opening up a
no like he's out 92 d5 and then we have
to deal with this diagonal yeah
understandably but I think f3 is gonna
be a good response to to e4 in pretty
much every case and then you can
recapture any number of ways the night
with the Queen so take on e5 this might
be actually aimed at preventing this
movie for it it keeps this Bishop on b8
a little bit stuck behind its own pawns
so do you play do you ever play E for
here as white just to lock this Bishop
up entirely then you can play move like
c5 and Bishop b3 and kind of play
against this dark squared bishop
takes no takes back all right we see a
trade on a one I think I like Queen Oh a
bishop takes I think I liked Queen takes
a one get the Queen off this open file
and you can bring a rook to d1 then to
challenge this black queen but say takes
with the the bishop instead
that hits the the B for pause yeah
now the before ponents on their attack
perhaps to play c5 yeah now I'm I'm not
so sure though I think black is getting
this movie for and after all which I
would have liked to prevent if at all
possible
oh you mean like efore and there may be
some Queenie five ideas yeah look
slightly slightly dangerous I think so
how do you defend before if you play C
five and let's say you're about Queen B
one the Queen B one makes a lot of sense
yeah I think before in response to to
anything here any response to anything
before in this we have to watch out for
some potential Bishop age two sacrifices
the Greek Greek gift sacrifice right
yeah even there's ideas like Knight g4
night h2 and the Knight f3 this is an
idea of scene once or twice before but
it probably doesn't work immediately
because the white knight would still be
guarding f3 this should be too I think
this this is the one that I didn't
didn't quite gel with me what this
Bishop I'm going back to this move
Bishop d3 no it seems like maybe this
Bishop b3 here perhaps was slightly
inaccurate because it just it forced you
to move again you know and we don't
really want to do that in opening you
like this defense of the queen of the d4
square as well yeah I like Bishop e2
here I would have done that B to counsel
the same approach before Bishop e2 I
think that way we don't have to deal
with this and then it's we don't have to
even worry about it for because we can
always go 92 yeah and the chief or
square is covered so I think Bishop if
you might have been slightly in accuracy
here and we're seeing some problems now
so c5 plate also simply b6 I wonder why
I black didn't decided not to go for
this efore move because I think this is
that would have been a really nice way
to get a lot of sure b6 trying to break
now Knight takes d4 pawn is on their
attack
okay doesn't look like block has too
many problems here yeah it's in Canton
white go for something like 94 here
that's what I'm wondering
94 and thank you for if captures Bishop
takes before that hitting home I think
c6 and and preventing plaque from
playing a for for just a moment Elise
yes take one before then I guess well
beyond is happy to take on FC is that
that looks actually very very nice Tom
takes f6 played that position
yeah I don't think I'd be upset if it
takes because then you have night aged
well you don't actually that's thinking
I was thinking about that we had 9h 40s
I would say absolutely but we don't have
night h4 there that could be so perhaps
maybe Queen e2 prepare rook b1 and a lot
of the black pieces are actually a
little bit loose yeah I agree in a long
run I think there will be a lot of
compensation there so the hallux deal
perhaps black can play like Bishop c4
there's to try to go Bishop age five
not Iman is a completely different idea
he plays Knight ft 5 and he basically
attacks the pawn before all right i--i
is there are two attackers home before I
have some dangerous ideas here are night
FG 5 9 FG 5 go get them
go get them all right so let's try to
understand Eve h 6h 6 I want to play
Queen Age 5 but I'm not so convinced
myself yeah I guess Knight takes you you
do have knight back to f6 yeah and then
I have a check with Bishop 8 7 but you
have King f8 so maybe maybe it's not
quite working like this piece is aiming
you know so I think needs to come up
with something if somebody anybody can
come up with some attacking ideas I
think Fabiano will I think he's the one
who it should we take a look at maybe
another game yet to see what development
we have this so let's look at this game
this is a game Domingues playing against
mariana and not Ayane you know proved to
be a very solid player he drew Caruana
in the first round first
even had some chances it's very now he
has the black piece is the black pieces
funny aim and what we have here we see
another solid position it's a pretty
interesting structure actually so white
has these CC pawns as does black but
white has just a little bit more space
yeah so we should be for play so the
question is see this this trade of
Bishops I don't think white wants to
take on B for the opening of the AF file
would be very nice for for black so f5
is gaining this kingside space perhaps
now we'll see a very rudimentary King
side attack rook f3 or gauge 3 and get
get the pieces to the King I guess you
didn't want to play the move 94 because
94 looked kind of interesting because
takes Queen d4 but yeah 94 I don't think
white would would capture that that
night how would he keep tonight is you
want night c1 maybe night g3 and just
bring this note into H 5 H 5 for
attacking purpose yeah ok but this looks
nice for why they think yes so he's
trying to actually walk the key to b7 I
think yeah what's what's really
expanding on the Kings side and I think
it's gonna take black some time to get
to b7 yeah I'm not so sure you have the
time because g5 is coming on on the next
move a great shade so try to discourage
g5 oh yeah so Rick g1 not Rick h1
White's not interested in actually
trading major pieces here he wants to
keep his rooks on the board for this you
know for this attack so Knight a 6 I
guess is trying to get Queen c5 to trade
off the major major pieces maybe we can
play c3 here with white guards to the be
Foursquare and against Queen c5 I might
play d4 giving up my my c4 pawn just for
this dark special any white this tool I
think has some chance to say name
definitely if you see this pawn land on
g6 actually you're on g4 to g5 then H
takes H take 7 g6 and have some real
problems with the g7 x keeping that
defender o'clock situations you know
it's about equal so I think I like Lynn
year's position I think
slightly slightly better here property
two now he's preparing really preparing
the move g5 yeah but now a Quincy five
is playable and I guess we will see that
X III King takes between Knight will
lend back on c5 play Knight c3 perhaps
and then try to maneuver the King back
and go g5 yeah that's the only reason
why I wasn't a little bit hesitant to go
for this endgame this a for pawn it's
gonna cause some problems I think but I
think we'll put the knight on c3 there
and so night before actually played okay
so we do have to defend c2 somehow or
maybe we'll just give it up but now of
course just erect c1 keeps the pond
defended now if 92 I'm expecting your g1
and now perhaps White's actually looking
to give up the c2 pump just play g5 here
go get on g5 is it working
Queen did you okay not yet he says not
yet
the Grandmaster patience that mountain
quietly not quite yet Oh b5 well that is
not a move I actually saw coming
well I the point is if you take yet
making maybe five check take on sheet2
oh I did domingus missed it I I missed
it as well so we do see takes takes
I mean I I've been ready to sacrifice
some of these queenside puns for a while
queen c5 I guess Queen III you can just
trade and take on c2 anyways yes maybe
King f3 here if Queen c2 just trade rook
c1 yes okay see a king f3 you can take
p5 but then I think this happy we have
our strong structure there oh wow d 4 4
wow this was a more attention this was
unexpected yeah they're playing some
really interesting chess here it's the
964 no quick things yeah yeah because 90
xt forfeits an IC to attack don't get
pinched don't wanna get to know us got
Queen d7 chick so yeah I would expect a
trade here and then King III just keeps
everything solid and the Black Knight is
actually a little bit short on squares
if Queen takes b5 I think you wants to
just call g5 n g5 looks powerful enough
to position a lot of looming threats
here for white you know isn't constantly
making threats on the Queen side she was
going to come I like this I think I like
this were linear deployment is down to 4
okay so he takes yeah I think he's he's
safe to get this let's move g5 in I
guess night c2 is blacks idea it's very
double-edged actually yeah I like g5 I
really like g5 yeah Knight suit - I
guess Quincy 3 maybe
yeah Queen c3 and you gain this this
tempo on the b6 check yeah I think you
have King f3 and then I was looking at
some take on taking on h h5 g far but
then the knight thing yeah the night on
that I don't see - isn't yet fixed it's
it's it's quite messy there there are
other alternatives in this position as
well so g5 but I think maybe Queen b6
must be played so like age 65 age 65 I'm
gonna be 36 okay
and if captures on f6
yeah it looks dangerous yeah g5 does
come through yeah no I mean once you put
the roofs like this you're you you gotta
go for it okay this looks I think I very
much like líneas position I think this
is tactically to Tamiya as it looks
looks to be working out so rook 8 to d8
so g6 there's King e7 keeping the rook
under okay can you take six years yeah I
mean they've brainwashed in that's the
probably not but the point here is you
take some before you play Oh Merc takes
G 737 take one everything have to cook
one chick and that's here mate so you
have to go back on the aged see a king
EA and then simply 1954 hitting the coin
yeah there's a queen c5 move yeah c3 but
then just make c6
yeah no brilliant Queen sacrifices today
it looks like but what can be done then
we have to meet this threat to where
Queen somehow maybe just queen c3 keeps
all the threats then Queen b6 chick yeah
King f1 there's Rick okay no I think
your father's little few wants so you
have to go King f3 but then there's her
h3 yeah I think you're just gonna play
it over g3 and play that position maybe
even King g4 there though gains time on
the rook oh no I'm sorry the Queen's on
c3 see we did okay Queen a7 not a move I
saw not a move I see something
he's keeping the pressure so you cannot
take on c2 Queen check and pick up the
pump pick up the piece very active play
here I'm very very active playing Wow
what about the rook to d2 now to Queen
67 okay this is really wild here what's
happening Kish
I don't I mean every move I haven't seen
how black is going to stop takes an f6
and every move he's come up with some
resource so far but you get the feeling
these resources might be running out
yeah the feeling the feeling is that
okay it's a very important 96 we have
Queen c7 so I yeah yeah I mean there's
there's no checks anymore if you play
Queen b6 white will simply trade the
queens and then take on f6 and Rick
takes g7 is going to be going to be
killer I think once these rooks get to
this seventh rank it's it's tough to
have to stop them
okay so maybe black can hope to survive
the position so Queen b6 check takes
takes takes on f6 takes enough six rook
g7 check what if I just play King e8 the
idea is next move with the King on the
background I think it's just gonna be
yep but next move I'm gonna play rook d7
and try to evict you hmm do you have
anything to do with that one tempo let's
see here
Queen b6 takes takes I think this might
be the way to try to survive it looks
very very unpleasant rook t2 Wow
this is throwing caution to the wind
okay well so Queen takes DC seven is a
check
yeah well that's that's this that's this
has to be played
oh the rook actually comes back I don't
I don't understand I just don't
understand well he's okay so you can't
exactly the Queen yet I don't want to
play it if we take what she takes f6
rook takes e7 roof to g7 again you
cannot take because we have the made
through g6 but again you go King e8 even
yet and if we take on c7 there's a Queen
b6 check of course that makes you wonder
though the Queen d7
I don't think it's working on 27 Queen
d7 there's a Queen e7 check there
now what about just Queen c3 yeah Quincy
3 seems seems natural
probably Queenie 5 there for 4 black
I guess you take out six yeah take one
left six so I think just clean yeah
please sit through this make sense I
mean b6 check okay
the king has to go somewhere maybe King
II won to dodge all the checks the only
problem is kinky one there might be a
doubling out the rooks idea
ah with checkmate to checkmate in the
background so so I guess King f3 is the
other option and the h3 check white is
the place to play rook g3 and one-sided
Rex does come off the board which is
good news for black
it's taking a quick look around I do
want to say Wesley cell has drawn his
game with Charlotte take a look yeah
let's take a look at Geoffrey seems to
be losing unless so what happened in
this game here we hit some looks like an
opening theory some shocking theory
so black takes the rook and why it takes
why it takes a drop why this must be
some very good prep from Wesley so I
would expect shock is is definitely
trying to win win yes these games so
what happened with Jeffrey's game I
don't know something something beyond my
comprehension
so he played that I played this center
counter I don't know you know the little
the little suspect little suspicious you
know against very top ranked Grandmaster
so he took a pawn actually but he's just
behind in development oh yes so let's
finish looking at this game I do want to
mention Fabiana has actually won his
game who's I believe he was playing with
two pieces against a rook and just a
tactic was missing by black here sorry
let's finish up the Geoffrey so yeah so
that's the same game and now basically
he's just under tremendous amount of
pressure this h5 is coming here and yeah
this just is just a really strange
opening choice 9 f7 yeah this is this is
nasty stuff yeah
just just just a bad opening choice by
Geoffrey he needs to just make sure he
doesn't get into trouble like this you
know
okay so we're expecting a loss from
Geoffrey let's go back to the Linea
Dominguez game though cuz oh very
important developments have happens okay
so oh well hold on well maybe now
Geoffrey isn't losing this looks this
just looks like a draw there's just
rooks III okichi - ah yeah so probably
he's gonna lose this game so far beyond
Oh warm but let's take a look at the
games that are in progress - yeah the
funny a game has blown up the queens are
off the board the white rooks did invade
but is it enough for white here so the
question is who is pushing here
I think definitely white is pushing this
marathon is nowhere near queening i-864
linear Dominguez final seconds I think
if this white rook on g1 can just find
an open file then checkmate is
threatened on the back rank so rook d1
is the threat for the moment we're d1 so
if so rook d2 prevents it but now rook
h1 rook h1 but then there's some
perpetual okay so King f3 and what's the
idea King g4 all right
oh no wait Ritchie - there's King wet
yeah King f41 side of rooks might come
off the board
okay so King F for it takes takes must
be played black needs to get rid of that
rook on g7 and now the king is coming
off the back rank and I think black is
perhaps surviving unless rook c1 is
powerful no okay Knight they try if
they'll still be in the dive as a threat
can black just start going just a four
just get me out of there a4 a3 a2 a1
I think that'll blue yeah I think that's
what black needs to do otherwise these
these threats around the King are going
to be too much so rook e1 is also a
solidifying move so Lenny it does take
this pawn also Geoffrey did end up
losing that endgame I do animation so
let's let's stay with this game so the
score is tied to everybody right now one
in half each yeah and the question is oh
well it looks like at night g3 defends
everything thank you three yeah but it's
just a draw hoped you want hey Ritchie
one King F for me
oh oh no when you hit flex oh oh my god
what happened oh you just didn't move
you just didn't move oh that hurts
oh wow so with that result the the score
I believe is actually tie tonight my
goodness yeah that's that's not not a
good look
from lenio Dominguez you cannot just
move sometimes just 93
yeah just 93 and there's not just a
drunk not a problem
maybe he didn't like f3 there or
something but yeah but I mean you you
still get six yeah f6 route g3 even King
F for f7 I mean oh yeah I mean Knight f6
check even
I just play movie just play a move
unbelievable
that one hurts no one hurts yeah okay
what do we see what happened in these
other games though he's got a lot of
time on the dole any a game there yeah
we did okay let's take a look at the
other games here so Fabiana
let's look at the positive side yeah
let's see my father then so if I be
warned the game thank God he was like a
man thinketh he won because you don't
look like what we need it if it looked
like he was doing that particularly
great here now he's down upon here I
mean he's got some compensation yeah but
he's not a pawn yeah it's a pawn okay
well I wanted a piece maybe you know all
is right in the world then Lenny a loses
on time in the drum position I'll be
done just hangs a piece - no yeah
Geoffrey X we analyzed that game int boy
Geoffrey's game didn't go quite
according to plan
well not the greatest finish to the
first half what happen it yeah this was
yeah this was yeah I didn't expect we
would lose that I thought it was just
gonna be a draw so what happened here
but why I play d4 why complicate so much
yeah I think what was wrong with King F
T
as simple as sometimes better I don't
know mistaking f3 looking I I mean the
problem a reason I came but anyway this
85 okay what happened here that we need
three did we discuss pink yeah I think
we're looking at you 3 F 3 and if
location H a group later to me takes
root G 3 I mean we're still have a pawn
we have a queen bee treat right there I
don't know it looked very pleasant for
white I mean I don't know what happened
but I think you're in the continuation
things we're looking why we lost the
same game Oh believable yeah you just
take up six and now now everything is
coming coming through well first of all
why why give up the pawn just check on
g7 first no even I think 93 would've
been a nice move
yeah 93 95 yeah very strange very
strange range hopeful 95 looks very
natural no 95 table it stinks I don't
know this is it's just a little
disturbing sing money everything is lose
the son game I I mean of course the the
final position is just a drop but you
know losing on time is just anything
just go kinky for here yeah keep the
night out of the game just see through
King before and in this case Lenny is
kind of reliance on this this time
pressure is it's just it's gonna bite
him that's the problem you know it just
it's if it's happening a lot it's a
problem all right
what yeah I mean I agree why don't we
take a look though at the results for
round 2 see where we stand after the
first half of play
we have fabio nikeyra wanna defeating a
bead on Lenny Dominguez of course
unfortunately losing that game tomorrow
yeah in a drilling position
yeah shock and Wesley got to a quick
draw and then Geoffrey is Zhang actually
lost to Derek lost a backwards on that
one
so final score so far is four to four so
even a playing field going on the line
to the board for for India yeah I am we
thought he'll be the guy that we can try
to get points off but so far he's
proving that not so easy one and half
out of two well with this halfway point
I think we are gonna take a quick break
and perhaps we have a sneak peek at
Norway chess as well where the finals
will take place for the crow chess
League don't go anywhere we will be
coming back with round three coverage
Norway the chess capital of Europe being
free and stable with Magnus Carlsen
it's the protest League finals at chess
party 2020 Caruana
so
boat Eze hammer Rudolf chess bras an
open Fischer random chess tournament
[Music]
will you be part of the world's biggest
chess party
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
found three coverage of this protest
League quarter-final match between the
st. Louis Archbishop's and the Indian
Yogi's my name of course is national
master kala dummy I'm joined by
Grandmaster Bart koban we will be giving
you the play-by-play coverage of this
round 3 we do have pairs really quickly
and I think the games themselves yeah of
course we have Bobby playing a Hare
Krishna
we have Linea Dominguez against shock
Mamba gr of Wesley so against Audubon I
know what's the so against Iranian and
Jeffrey Zhang against Audubon here in
this third round why don't we just jump
right into the games though as we are
tied four to four
yes yeah a little bit surprising but we
we lost around to match two and a half
one and a half yeah yeah hates there was
an accident by Domingues
flogging in a drone position and Jeffrey
had a cool game yes lost so we'll see
but you were very strong team we
hopefully can bounce back in this round
so we have Fabiano playing card Krishna
so we have a Robbie's black so so far
Anton h3 played so Knight b6 what I know
Caleb sometimes they go early and five
in this position so that's why you have
to put the bishop on b3 yeah so now King
is on h8 and next move is f5 so white so
d4 alright plays d4 yeah you know before
black even gets going with this King
side attack breaking through in the
center yes so d4 how is black go in
response to this threat
you can't play f5 anymore probably
because it's actually not in the
position yeah I'm not sure I'm not sure
exactly because yeah if if we just go
back here yeah if I would be just
perfect then we have a very easy game to
play but now
f5
okay my concern is just take well I
think maybe take on e5 and then I'll
take only fine maybe I can take on e4
and hope for some kind of group takes e4
Bishop f5
what about 2066 there's more in between
us
Bishop takes d6 maybe some kind of
Marshall Marshall type of pawn sacrifice
we will have some lead in development
but Fabiano didn't like it takes on d4
instead okay so he wants to be 85 move
from Fabi nice nice prediction okay so
case 3 probably going to see something
like right there should be six and then
a Bishop f6 from fabi's individual
putting more pressure on this team pink
on h8 looks slightly slightly a little
awkward but it's fine I think yeah this
looks reasonably fine here I don't see
any any serious problems here it's a
pretty natural iqp position yeah Queen
d7 okay d8
yeah maybe even f6 if he has the time f6
would be good you know that Queen d7
yeah the reason I say f6 because then I
can go Bishop g8 and protector seven
just just keep everything but the
problem here is Queen d3 I don't like
this Queen d3 idea don't want to be
short you know do you actually see
Knight takes c3 here and then maybe
Bishop c4 just to play against this idea
it's a little bit strange but I think a
little bit worried about that plan
because of maybe perhaps he has 92 and
Queen h5 yeah 92 is it's a good move but
I like these positions where I can take
on c3 as long as I keep control over all
these light squares
I think after Bishop f6 to control to
what to deal with these h7 threats
Bobby's probably gonna be playing g6 you
do have to look out though for some
tactics on on the e6 square this bishop
six so I guess queen d3 will be a fall
tomato pie I just simply g6 yeah and I
was saying you have to be a little bit
careful though with this bishop on e6
there's always sort of takes these six
ideas but not in the immediate position
so simply rook e8 kind of negate some of
those threats by giving this bishop
another defender but yeah I'm kind of
still stuck with this idea I still want
to play things like takes on c3 and then
maybe Knight a5 and just cement this c4
square down so you want to play against
that this is kind of like a hooter
blockade
yeah yeah I think if Bobby has time
Knight takes c3 Knight a5 in b5 are kind
of some really nice ideas to just put
the night off c4 yeah you can even
follow up with c6 and Bishop d5 and
there are some attacking chances there
for awhile yeah because you know the
Queen sets up queen d3 just six but
there might be more attacking chances if
you allow a move like 94 to come through
you want to stop you 94-95 yeah I agree
yeah it's not not so easy yeah not so
easy here so if you didn't play 94
unless you play cooky 8 so I think we
should be they should be three that's
this is that something offering that's a
little soft move no it's a list because
it's not hmm you're kind of walking in
your ear uh Connie you wanna yeah it's
not not the best I think though the idea
is he's simply preparing 94 you couldn't
play 94 last turn due to Bishop f5 with
some tactics I think but here now maybe
94 is as an idea looks looks reasonable
for Fabi though I think he's got this
kind of Queen side positional edge she
just needs to make sure these these
Kings side threats don't actually break
through for a hard Krishna
so yeah Knight ce7 is is a very
intuitive move actually against the iqp
more control of d5 and you free up your
C pawn a little bit
first see six ideas even see five ideas
opening up the bishop yeah and if Queen
yeah and also I like this night sister
because if Queen D three then you know
Bishop f5 multi Bishop a5 as well
94 and of asking for c5 isn't is it can
Bobby brothers creates five idea
sixty-three night takes III rook takes
III maybe 9f5 I'll take the trip pixie
frog things like that move actually
so if pond takes he's happy to go to the
endgame Black is fine there if Rope
takes it rook takes perhaps 96 96 right
and then of working for Bishop a5
there's a rookie eight there there's
working at that fish soul okay so you
have to do better maybe just maybe rook
takes just Nitin d5 maybe you can you
can also just play c6 and then just the
knight on d5 no I think it's just this
looks okay for for block here doesn't
look like a doesn't look like yeah so he
took with the rook okay after after some
consideration he took back with a rook
okay so um yeah I like the move Knight
d5 I like the move c6 just keep things
solid you do still have to look out
though there's these Kings side so 96
now the night is a great defender of
this long diagonal in the rook has to
move rook h5 probably gonna see
something like c6 plate
okay good still you know okay but let's
take a look at some other game so gauge
five maybe a just night back to F yeah
sorry maybe there's not a fate and then
you can play this I deal with f6 to see
everything just safe and solid yeah yeah
but okay so let's see Leslie so against
Narayan the solid the hero for the
Indian TV so far it's really very solid
position here so we have looks like
Italian and pretty solid position here
the rest is trying to outmaneuver his
opponent and is doing a little dance
back to f1 and f2 g3 look at the F Phi
square also two minute disadvantage here
for Vesely on the clock at the moment he
needs to feel standard yeah he's taking
his time submission c5 perhaps it seems
like a natural idea for black just get
the bishop on the best diagonal and
white he's really 9f5 Kim I'm gonna play
Knight f5 takes pawn takes a 5-inch yeah
that actually looks pretty reasonable
but but maybe I can just take on III and
Queen takes c3 just play f6 and the
bishop on c2 actually looks a little bit
suspect sorry you know after Bishop c5
Knight f5 will do play I want to take on
that five takes and then take on a3
Queen takes f6 I just want to lock
things down there's ship afloat like
it's the bishop okay Bishop e4 yeah no
pressure I think I think that's probably
what he wants to do mm-hm I feel like
that position actually there's a small
plus for a white because you also have
the pawn on a chick so later on we might
see some light squares because you
really need to regroup in that position
to put the night away and put c6 and
that might not be so easy to do so and
the good news is you don't have g6 if
you a g6 skin g7 then I think there is
absolutely nothing to worry about but
just six dropping the h6 pause so in the
mind is gonna Knight is gonna lend on
that five whistle is kind of just in
time to get this idea through so maybe
those extra minutes we're well spent
okay Knight a5 now comes in okay so the
question is expecting maybe we won't and
Queen Anne fate take its Queen a fatal
move here so I feel like this should be
for idea I think convinced I don't want
to take that I don't know but then your
queen afraid is the only move your queen
I think it looks dangerous though it
looks like you're asking for a long way
in Queen chief or I like I like Queen g4
I think is is there
takes on III and then Jesus saying but
but there's no trick after g6 yeah you
can just play your gauge 3 and then the
on and h6 will be will be falling yeah
so I think now okay with this I feel
like he's gaining some momentum now
we're not paid but ya know this this
queen g4 idea looks like strong yeah I
think queen g4 needs to be played what
else
maybe Queen h5 is a consideration as
well I would have mine h4 h4 as I move -
yeah just h4 well I think it should be
super interesting uh-huh they should be
three interesting approach now if he
wants to take a B wait if you take
there's also clean g4 that needs to be
looked at okay so he's trying to divert
the business promotion tactics yeah some
tactics the knight on c6 is definitely
misplaced and yeah but with the way that
Wesley's handle this I think 97 is one
tempo away so you have to be very
careful so Bishop takes b3 probably
queen g4 now no he just picks okay he
just takes because 97 days before so the
good news is you don't have a phase King
each this is better not be better for
white the Queen has to come back to even
if you get g6 and this is still white is
doing really well here well first of all
the next move actually could be even b5
Queen afraid be five maybe even yeah
Queen effete I thought maybe even Queen
c4 just this is quite pleasant now for
white I agree yeah doing a good job here
yeah Queen C fourth
I like Queen C for fluency for it yeah
b5
looks as good as you mentioned that it
is at some point you know yeah the one
thing you have to avoid this trading the
Knights yeah that's what we see for does
a good job you know with that would be
five its yeah wondering what you would
play h4 a place
so what does a response to 97 93 93
always keep you gotta keep one pair of
tonight 83 but then c64 black maybe
maybe it's consolidating a bit I can to
avoid this the only thing I can think of
here
Caleb NC 4 maybe he didn't like rook d2
invasion detail
ok but I need to be tweeze hanging and
it seems I don't know it doesn't seem
quite quite right though for black does
b5 work it takes beat Queen takes B it's
a lot of pressure
yeah rupa takes a long I guess Queen
takes a little takes a one maybe g6 I
like whites there's still 93 and 95 yeah
I mean there's also Queen takes b7 I
think and that okay so okay so now he
wants to go Queen f7 so Queen C for
needs to be played here in Quincy for
hitbad c7 pawn yeah but that probably
c64 black six year and then okay just
play that position that's that's that's
too a very pleasant position for white I
agree more space and definitely the
better night and after c6 that the b6
pawn are the starting the b6 Corey does
look a little bit weak she's just just
go to key d1
yeah just challenged the file yeah the
e6 square is looking a little bit a
little bit tender as well for a queen to
land on rook d7 I I still like your move
for d1 I think I'll go with the Eirik
but there's also b5 once again to
consider before yeah the the only thing
now he can take and then with the roof
on this seven you can please six I'm
hoping the alacrity
we can get something in this one so
and now how do you keep up the threats
how do you keep up the threats it's not
so easy
can play maybe Queenie six swap for
everything
yeah and all right the Sakura Queen and
Knight endgame could be something but
then would our night is a little bit
misplaced so we need some time yeah we
need position the night I don't see how
you coordinate the pieces look black
there either okay Queenie I think I like
this line actually four six takes the
snack comes back to III and how do you
actually get through those yeah warden
eight it's not so easy Queen only six is
very annoying I mean it's yeah the
problem is once you move this night off
of East seventh an the squares on d5 and
f5 both become available to the White
Knight against the Queen these six
doesn't solve your problems Queen b6
Queen f7 problems are still remaining
yeah things like Knight g4 could be
threats as well after h5 wait wait wait
wait this this cannot be good Cecilia
quit seven you can't play King aged six
I'll play Queen takes Knight yep it's
just wins Queen f7 wins basically yeah
there's nothing to do they just fall
fantastic fantastic yeah it's right was
a bad move there we go Wesley so of
course the tactic King h6 they'll see
Queen takes Knight nice cats cats killer
that was quick to nice sharp tactics I'm
trying to get Mike to play mean fire he
won't put me on the day today especially
if you don't like grandmasters is still
not enough it won't put me on the team I
don't know with the current format
things with unlimited
okay this is looking great dynein
Wesley's gonna pick up upon an age five
yes I think yeah finally they're gonna
be able to our team is gonna be able to
crack then not I am strong I was a far
beyond Oh doing here probably on a huge
time edge notably huge age yeah and I
think the position itself the rook on a
seven is actually looking a bit strange
I think Bobby's the only one pressing
here yeah Bobby is definitely pressing
here let's take a look here in this game
because this is the one I'm a little bit
yeah Lenny a down on time once again but
with all oh it's just completely she's
completely winning he's up to pawn and
shocked is shocked just dead structures
dead shocked just plenty it needs to
play move though why isn't he playing
Bishop e6
yeah shock just ah I know this line okay
so stings went wrong here this is all
theory but some of this is theory but
okay thank you I think shock mixed up
the line here you supposed to play rook
do you wanna hear that line you can go
for this route d1 here
yeah no it's not alone castle this is
looking a bit familiar I think it was a
game is played actually yes yes so
that's a huge win for us we take down to
a board one of the huge Mumbai Domingues
redeeming that little accident bravo
Bravo linear gives us the win and we
expect Vesely win aggressively has value
a stick well we actually saw that taxi
appear on the board with beautiful yeah
I guess it was a wake-up call you know
the last song was a little wake-up call
here let's see now players getting back
home Geoffrey is doing we need Geoffrey
to play well oh no Geoffrey is falling
for some tactics of look no with
Geoffrey's winning a queen but just as
losing all his pieces what's going on
here so it looks like rook takes c3
retake c1 King f2 bishop c3 and then
Queen c7 oh my goodness but I think it's
working out I think you end up with a
queen for two rooks what's going on he's
again in huge trouble out of the opening
what is going wait what's working out so
okay that's not the line ex-patient g5
yeah I did not expect this line I
thought Geoffrey would play rook takes
c3 oh yeah yeah what's going on today
down a couple pawns so it looks like
that's so good you need a miracle in a
theater so Rick c2 keeps the rock out
but two pawns has enough coupons enough
we're still opening
okay play the song and open ink and then
yeah Jeffrey just something designs
believable yeah unfortunately top from
Jeffrey
there is the one more game in progress
let's see if Fabi can try and convert
this last game against Hari Krishna
looks like just looks a little bit stuck
now on H three years Jeffrey just
perform a little bit better this match
would have been over
yes but let's focus on the good here I
think Bishop d5 is a really strong move
from Fabi
you're gonna play Bishop f3 and you're
gonna take the g4 upon but you've waited
but wait maybe you do so maybe not
that's a good I wouldn't want to risk it
I would I would like to win the match
yeah I'd like to win the match with two
and a half at least I would want to go
to the final with so what my only
concern is that if you play wreck a Jake
here maybe there's gonna be some
pressure on seven I mean if you played
okay two orders f3 yeah so what's to be
done
ricochet I guess we should analyze this
line I was expecting her a seven okay a
seven threat this Knight f5 but I guess
the good news for five we should be
three maybe
yeah Bishop d3 guards that square you
can also maybe just play rook b8 and
there's also this Knight day okay B
should be alive he goes for this after
all
Wow so this is the the first line I gave
but far you were saying this looks a
little bit risky connected palms but I
think he calculated it he also has some
very strong checkmating threats after
this apology I think still I think I
think we should be should be ok here you
know with it's much harder to play for
my chart it took play for all right
crash Carter Krishna and you know then
of course there's also the huge time
edge that Bobby has ok something Bobby
is done up a lot ok for now maybe at
like Rica for just keep everything under
control but now white probably plays
this move b5 and we have four g4 I think
okay b6 now we need the rook back in the
games yeah rook b3 is a pretty strong
threat here so maybe a rook d4 yeah
before 54:57 but then I I think the
pawns are kind of rolling probably not
rook rook d7 probably should be serious
to control everything you can also
insert a rip d1 check yeah do you want
chick can go in a bishop you said then
you got a five or four colors yeah King
g5 and g6 a5 and King h4 + f4 ins unless
you can force these pawns through on it
on the a and B files I think whites are
simply gonna get checkmated of course so
far the score in this round is two to
one
this is the final game still in progress
here Bobby's trying to make it 3-1 in
this third round which would really put
the India Yogi's in a tough spot
in fact Rick do you wanna was powerful
enough that hard christian just plays do
you want to see one but now i think rick
d3 is picking up upon right well Rick d
3 a 4 and then ok so he just goes for
the Kings side I like this as well so
the plan is to try to go to view on this
should be selling now if it should be 7
okay Rick D aid but ok b7 but this
losses losses
pawn right I think this three versus oh
so this was his idea but no we can just
take on b7 and then I guess where it
takes the five this is how I should play
D should be seven it would it be so much
easier
yeah okay Oh for but now this this F
pawn Falls looks like a drop looks like
a draw
yeah I'm not sure there's any way to
fight for the win here still you have to
take me seven and then after takes one
up for what really has no any chances
but with a draw we still move to two six
and a half so I don't think we're in too
much danger
so which move you're suggesting I just
work takes be seven I have four check
yeah King f7 rook be serve them Bishop
takes me seven I mean I don't think like
except for losing with this long bishop
oh wow g5 so Fabi still trying to create
some problems but I think it's it's just
gonna be rotates b7 and and a drama and
game yeah just probably just time to
call it call Cole of the day yeah yeah
risking a bit too much I think if you
leave the beep on on the board so now
this Bishop can both control the pawn on
g4 and Corral this this a pond at the
same time and blacks King and plenty of
time to come to the center of the board
shouldn't be any problem here holding
this for Fabi
and now maybe even just king d5 I think
you can get to this a pawn take it off
the board yeah the sacrifice that they
should put the final pawn yeah
yes we do cking d5 now this night move
makes a threat but we'll just move the
bishop out of the way although just just
Bishop h1 now maybe you should be tteyuu
Bishop - maybe - and now you lose the
jeep on but you do gain the a pawn and
once again the bishop can sacrifice
itself for the final bond and no
problems here for for black you can even
play g4 I suppose just keep this palm
tree but make it harder you know Bishop
f3 oh so he gives the punt but of course
this is a dead drop a dead drop calling
it dead yeah Bishop Bishop e6 baby yeah
why it's trying to box this king out
okay
it's simply Bishop e6 yeah
or the check the check works too I yeah
now King be for and nothing to be done
the King has made it back
King deliver you with losses if you let
a for Cap'n that's the only way you
would lose this okay so so now with the
bishop eyeing f5 from afar this King is
gonna control the e4 square then there's
no way to block the diagonal and there's
no way to advance the pawn so we do
actually see now Bishop takes pawn and
okay good result plus one of course begs
us to have six in half again but we
still need one and a half a hand for
minor of course we do have drawn in this
match thanks to our regular season
performance so we just need to get to a
point but we still need to run in half
points so plus one is not enough for the
immediate great result result in this
round I mean just just a pity to
Geoffrey Geoffrey today he's such a good
player so the same opening he played
against my madero actually mm-hmm
and you know he got a very solid
position okay so if three yeah I mean I
like what he's done so far
Queeny to miss Bishop on e3 is gonna
fill the dark squared weaknesses what is
this tactic so I guess there's this
Queen c5 check so perhaps yeah he
probably overlooked this night of course
so probably the easiest thing would have
to do you're just Bishop C to wipe
everything off and just enjoy that
slightly better position trade
everything off there's no tactics
nothing I think he's just it's just a
pleasant position for Geoffrey I mean
not of course an understandable miss
though he missed the Queen g5 and Queen
c5 tactics so basically after this you
if you go to have two Queen g5 Queen
Queen g5 22 you get mated yeah and
basically just check and he takes and
now he's this is very unpleasant because
block is yeah yeah yeah this comes down
to that the thing that you know putting
the pit when you're under pressure you
want to liquidate the pressure that's
why you should play Bishop to liquidate
even though it seems like it's a
but then he played the aggressive move
heading the loose piece as soon as you
put a piece on an undefended error
that's attacked a very very strange move
by Jeffrey and after this just went down
the hill I mean he's just it's just this
is very unpleasant now and the pawns
just fall and then we saw Jeffrey end up
in this losing although I do want to
pause here I thought Brooks t1 or t3
could you play rook takes c3 actually I
just rook e1 check bishops III and Queen
c7 birthday three four many pieces yeah
there's there's no way okay whenever you
see a position look III have now
whenever you see this loosen as in this
dark square Bishop on the board this is
just too much it's just too much yeah
this is just oh and he didn't even try
here yeah he thought it just completely
hopeless oh he's down two putts he's
down to punch something I thought it was
just one now it's enough anyway for now
her luckily luckily we have Wesley so
coming through and Oh Mingus mami Giotto
here yeah
muster just mixed up openings it was
Queens gambit declined yeah this yeah
get them to some very sure you supposed
to play Ruby do you want here yeah that
line that he was possibly looking do you
want any plate here and something he
mixed up I don't know what exactly but
the night before in this this King is
just too weak now especially with the
king's army abouts you should maybe take
back with a poet's list here you know be
able to prevent
takes with the e pawn maybe there's some
problem
if you take with a pawn but this did the
way he played he just lost oh yeah you
couldn't even develop I don't actually
understand why don't you takes I'm not
sure I think you just missed something
well perhaps you know we've seen some
bad games from our players today but I
don't think it is this level this was
just you know this was just really
really cool play by Mahmoud Yoda
well why don't we take a look at our
round for parents very critical periods
we need one in house
we need one in half so it all fine yeah
to this final round where Ianno
white against five and we take a look at
Fabiano's game because i think he
probably missed something there's
there's a moment I wanna oh yeah
absolutely from round three Fabi against
shocked mom in your of on board one
millennia dominguez takes on Iranian
Hardy Kirk oh wait I think we actually
have a little bit of a mix-up there in
the pairings I think Wesley so is
playing Hari Krishna yeah
however because Nana has already played
yes no that was an accident game where
yes accident happened Domingues that was
it getting that onion so yeah
in round four we will have Bobby again
shocked Lennie eight against Hari
Krishna Wesley so against Audubon and
Geoffrey Zhang against an Iranian on
board for so round four of courses that
match up we're bored one place bored one
or two plays board two and so on and I
was been saying I think this is really
where the archbishop shine when you get
these head-to-head matchups the top
boards against the top boards yeah and
that's when Fabi Wesley money a are
really gonna gonna show their stuff yeah
here we do have the actual things of
course as we said Bobbie against shock
Linney a against Hari Krishna
Wesley against Audubon and Jeffrey shop
again so we have white in one in three
right so yeah Bobby and Lenny actually
both have white on the top tube have to
wear white coat it'll be up to Wesley
and Jeffrey to kind of hold down the
fort with black and this time around and
then leave it to leave it to the
superstars too much to get it done
obviously limited so the well Wesley
Wesley playing
extremely well he scored 20 half out of
three Wesley has really I think it's
safe to say been the MVP for the
Archbishop's this year he gets it done
every week incredibly consistent
I think it's on positive every week so
far which is incredibly tough to do
absolutely yeah it's just so again the
situation is we have six in half
five in half right now yes we need eight
points to qualify to the finals of
course we see the bracket here and
notably from this bracket China has
already defeated the Germany bears to
advance to the finals in Norway now
we're hoping to do the same against the
new Yogi's here with just one and a half
points to go that's all we need to get
to these finals and yes I guess it's on
Thursday Thursday we'll have we'll be
there Marshalls against Armenian Eagles
and Friday Canadian chess crossed
against Chicago wind this week will be
will determine the finals no Armenia no
stranger to the protest League finals
either they want the Canada test bras of
course always a strong contender always
a strong they have a very strong team
with Alexander Greece Chuck yeah leading
up the squad yeah and these gears as
well nice teary refuge are very tough
people so I do want to mention though
during the regular season the team that
gave us the most trouble actually not
the kid in the chest bras it was the
Chicago wind yeah we barely narrowly
defeated them in our match so perhaps
they're gonna be a team to look out for
absolutely Gago wind is mostly the
players from Webster University Webster
unit range there they're definitely
gonna be on Form yeah
tough talk to you look out for
absolutely yeah so see critical need
nail-biting round awaiting us so we were
hoping maybe we don't have to be here
but yeah it all comes now we'll be
already much more safer we'll be in a
safer zone you know what I mean I have
to wait a half-point edge though
definitely it's not the most
uncomfortable position to be in
it's a half point agent Plus that we
have the tiebreak so it helps basically
at the moment we have a one-point lead
yeah you know well yeah yeah and in a
sense that eight eight also will make us
go through two
so that is to say the indie Yogi's it's
not good enough for them to just go plus
one in this final round they need plus
two to advance to the pond yes basically
they need three and a half the they need
three to one score yes and you know one
in half will be enough for our team
archbishops to go through the finals so
question is Jeffery can he play a solid
game a solid game against Narayan you
know this last two games hasn't been
both have been very loose yeah I mean I
really like Jeffrey is a great player
but today just somehow be too loose you
know with my opinions both games you
know I think Jeffrey isn't the type of
player really prone to tilting but so
with this rapid game and the rounds
running so far he's you know kind of
fall into if you remember the World Cup
last year you remember what he did there
eliminating onigiri now he and few
others he won three rounds actually he
beat yawns Christophe as well and yeah
onigiri yeah so he can yeah he is
extremely strong so just from how not at
his best so far but hopefully in the
last round he can come through you know
it would be nice to see Jeffrey do well
in the last game yeah I mean he hasn't
spent much time so far I think he's just
within the last year when he crossed
2,700 but that is really he's he's
becoming one of the best players in the
entire world and so he needs to start
showing that stuff you know it's that
consistency that gets you to that
reading and so he needs to show it here
in this final round about to start about
to start again the score is six in half
for archbishops five in half for India
Yogi's yeah well while we're getting set
up here why don't we take a look at some
upcoming events here at the st. Louis
chess club we've got some really excited
sounding stuff going on
of course the candidates tournament will
be going on all the way over in Russia
featuring these players and actually of
course like seen having a really strong
last couple of years and very pretty
much deserving the spot the candidates
and we will be doing live coverage of
this tournament from the st. Louis Chess
Club
be sure to follow along starting March
17th through April 4th we'll have some
really exciting stuff for you absolutely
on the show
very exciting stuff in just a few days
basically it's next week and next week
starts I also want to mention coming up
is the spring chess classic be sure to
keep an eye on that as well we will also
be doing coverage of this tournament and
one of the the Archbishop's is actually
playing actually I think a couple of
your Archbishop's are playing yes I'm
playing myself Jeffrey Jeffrey a
champion of the Spring Classic I believe
yeah yeah he won't determine last year
yeah I think he's the first player to
actually repeat the spring chess chess
classic spring 3 and then he's also won
I think a summer chess classic as well
yeah he gained a lot of points and
actually gained a lot of points in this
tournaments he does really well this
tournaments actually worked perfectly
for Jeffrey he was about 26 50s and he
gained quite a lot of points in this
tournament so yes this is where Jeffrey
is and we got some game scale up we got
to do the last round critical games have
just started so let's jump into it we
see Fabio once again put me for Bobby's
white against mommy Dro
mama Dianna just lost a really bad game
here so he's gonna come out he's gonna
come out you know swinging and trying to
do something here definitely but you
know we know that against Fabiano it's
very dangerous
yeah but I mean wait to play overly
aggressive it's go time
Yogi's know they need to score or they
need to be trying to score a victory on
on pretty much every board here to have
a chance yes a-five looking at a c4
square and I do like blacks Bishop all
the way on g7 here that's a good person
I agree that's a good Bishop here maybe
Knight c3 and you need some pressure
yeah nine threes okay I mean h3 is a
possibility or to just I just don't want
to allow Bishop g4 understand as you can
tell from the opening from the get-go
here mama tiara was just trying to get
something in balance here yeah
objectively you know why should be
better here tonight only five
objectively yeah but so night bd2 keeps
an eye on the c-4 square as well
which is really the night's only only
outpost this will see sixes plate I just
like hassles just get out of the center
Black's not ready to open up the center
with this king still on e8 so C takes D
is not gonna be playing so the notion is
now how to win a put a knight on D to
the drawback about the night on the tool
you block your dark square Bishop yeah I
think I like maybe a rook b1 move Bobby
just take first well can you take yeah
take first that way we don't have to
worry about having to lose ya the pawn
on d5 could be problematic
I do like unpinning though and then we
can move this beep on maybe put this
Bishop on p2 Oh a 4 is another way to go
about things putting pressure on this b5
pawn if you push it to be for what is
Bobby's idea maybe Knight and b3
bringing a night in to d4 well let's see
so the capture has occurred and he did
not take back he's simply castled yes
but now you cannot take with your a deny
because he'd be okay so now okay so we
do see a takes beat and I'm gonna be 93
does put some more more pressure on this
open open file and I don't know it's
kind of uncomfortable for black here
there's just this deep on sitting on d6
probably Bishop e6 or Bishop b7 yen's I
don't think white is in a rush to
capture on a5 but yes it's still tough
to develop the dark squared bishop due
to this pressure because of the b2 upon
I think it's roughly equal here in this
position because you know Tompa see the
dis exponents me but also we're tied up
to the b6 sponsor yeah definitely though
we're okay with the draw we just need to
not lose any game any games that's even
I want to keep an eye on a free game
here so just yeah how is Geoffrey doing
so far solid that's good
all right I love to see he play the
solid opening Queens gambit accepted and
and he knows the match situation so draw
is perfectly fine here and take some
queenside space oh my god is doing the
eight is coming up
eventually the the DNC Ponzi see three
squares a good square for the block and
it's interesting that white allowed pawn
to b4 quite so quickly I don't they
played this plunk but I believe in white
you shouldn't have a knight on c3 to do
this plumbing yeah you put the knight on
g2 you play a value maybe four but he
lost so much time I mean the point of a4
is you provoke before to loosen the c-4
square but your knight can't come to
soup or if you put a lot of time to
spend yeah to do that so that's why I
like I like what Geoffrey is doing I
like his position so ok 53 maybe some
threats on on the h7 square but nothing
Bishop 27 I think we're fine just okay
58 put the pawn on h6 just they saw the
Queen be a 28 so yeah white is eyeing
this a six pawn but should be okay for
the moment yes since the knife is still
in front of it so okay does open and now
there's no Knight e5 tricks cuz Knight
c3 is is strong if you capture back with
the night there is nice e5 here yeah I
think this is accurate play so far we
have this funny Knights they're facing
each other no like the powerful Knights
square so now this should be one perhaps
there should be one there's a lot of
pressure on the b3 upon it yeah first of
all if you go Bishop c2 there there
there is no tactic sorry there I was
thinking about Bishop C 294 takes Queen
c4 but there's a fish page 7 yeah the
discovery yeah
yeah I don't know so far it just looks
looks very comfortable for Jeffries
you're actually the one with more space
here yeah
more space a little bit more time on a
clock I like this this is how I think
you should play perfect okay Lenny a
we can check it out looks like Lenny a
is winning upon their knees wide and
he's he's crashing
I'm surprised sorry Krishna please be 45
that's like you're 45 in a must-win
situation match yeah I mean looking at
the current position I like is why just
you're not gonna play late you're not
gonna up lately need this kind of no I'm
just surprised you chose like some
Sicilian or something yeah well I mean
to be fair he does have black against
Lenny and I think this is the the
biggest mismatch well no not not with
Hari Krishna forgot líneas our board -
you have 4/3
Wesley so has actually already drawn his
game against Audubon and so that's a
huge result for us well every draw gets
us closer I don't I don't understand
what he seems you a drink I mean how are
they just giving up like what's
unbelievable I thought everyone would be
pushing h4 h5 yes Frank to me no I mean
they have to be playing for a win here
if they're going to win the game win the
match well he already miss plated yeah
Wow great for us all right
that's that's a good good draw for us I
do want to say though I think Lenny is
just winning upon and like possibly the
game in his current position Queen b5
attack c5 attack safe it's over I mean
how do you defend the pawn we are there
7 points right now we need one more
point
one more point to clinch to punch the
tickets
absolutely the finals also go away no
but yeah I mean the money is just
winning a pond it may be black and try
to hold yes c5 I guess just queen takes
a funny Queen a5 I think maybe it's
better to give up the the e pawn somehow
but there's no there's no way to defend
a5 but problem is there's no contra
plate killer yeah there's nothing I'm
just to be honest I'm just shocked they
know this is crazy what India Indian
Yogi's are doing it is wrong I thought
they will be just like going after with
Sicilians with dragons
yeah you know Knight doors this is not
the showing for the final round this is
just basically they just give up yeah
just playing D 45 symmetrical yeah
surprising but anyway very happy with
is to be heating up a little bit okay
Bishop III plate so the night is on
their attack it's a queen takes a to
will take on d4 there's a Knight f3
check tactic maybe but you simply take
it that you and just take on b5 always
eliminate that b5 + so there is no no
passed pawn or anybody wrong running
down the board there yeah and it's gonna
say the structure after Knight f3 and G
takes actually isn't all that bad for us
there's not enough there's not enough
pieces on the board for block to be able
to organize an attack there so maybe
we'll see this Knight move but what like
where to go where to go there's but
should be three coming next for for
white I believe it's very hard to see
how mama Garib is gonna play this
position and yeah and so very him
actually taking a little bit of time
here getting a bit of a deficit trying
to find some way to 56
yeah Queen d5 actually looks like they
mean you don't Knight 9595 can I can I
just
caveman f4 maybe Bishop d4 there is a
bit a bit more just million 395 a knight
c4 we can take g7 we could take c4 we
can take these over totally totally dead
yeah again a bit shocking to see I'll be
blunt just repeat yeah that that's
that's crazy
that's that's a crazy early draw from
with the white pieces you you really
need to be pushing here I mean of course
it's opponent is Leslie so it's not so
easy to push just completely shocking
did okay
he pushes a 5 okay we should be one play
Bishop f6 d5 and he says you know I'm
gonna take that b3 pawn pretty fun if
it's free it's for me well what is what
is not I am NOT I am gonna do now I
think you just miss play yeah but the
bishop on c2 because Knight moves away I
think Jeffrey's taking the
and heating that rook with the temple
might see won't it be attacking the
Queen yeah I mean there's there's no
time to play some discovery with the
night because you can simply capture
this reference there's a queen C to
trick but we C to trick Knight takes
Queen I don't know if that's what we
think their faith that's something you
have to calculate maybe there's e4 here
this is e for work just to block off
this diagonal here before
it just takes Queen c2 maybe then eat
for no that doesn't make any sense I'm
sorry you just take it no but you can't
just take once you wanna take on c1 you
can take an 870 looking around you see
the danger with the benefit was a night
landing alright
also though the the e5 pawn is abilities
a lot going on here but I think Jeffery
might have calculated it well enough I
think it's looking good this extra be
pawn is going to be very very strong
the recipe just finishes game and now
watching yeah
where to keep an eye here on Geoffrey
Jean on board for Jeff you're not having
the best match so far but it seems like
this one is it's going his way I also
want to say Lenny a did win that a pond
and the son game looks very very
pleasant for him I think he's he's just
going to win this game this past a pawn
is it's way too much he's just a pawn
so basically what happened just c5 was
play takes beat three and maybe money I
could have even just taking this pawn I
don't I don't see why not
we straight Queen c3 is solid I don't
know maybe he was worried about like rip
d3 or something some sacrifice with 9h
wife coming but okay I mean I'm just
saying things I don't know if it's true
but yeah a Queen's victory keeps that
black rook out eliminates all counter
play okay play b3 even Queen C 3 hits
e5 yeah b3 Ibuki 392 Knights e-40 when
it's needed
nice it's over Fabiano against this
should be a draw let's see what happened
in that game yeah so we were saying
there's this pressure on the night you
took and so now all the pieces just fall
off the board takes this n games nothing
despite the outside postpone there's
yeah no way to press here in fact uh
yeah mama draw B 3 so that puts us at 7
and 1/2 7 and a half we need half a
point to go in a week here we get a half
point do it from two two positions can
we get a half a point yeah and now Queen
c2 does come on the board in Jeffrey's
game Oh Jeffrey's game okay yes I so
okay so queasy to here as well and up 85
it's just Queen takes e5 takes d5 takes
place off the Queen takes II don't wait
to lose this there's no way to lose this
I mean maybe maybe Queen takes d5 isn't
the best winning tribe but we don't need
a win we just need a draw
like I like even 95 clearly to take
stake for the look behind the postponed
idea yeah I just push it 95 is a bit
better keeps winning how how is jeffrey
doing i would like to see Jeffrey win so
we did see this Queen c2 line come on
the board as we were expecting yes and
now it's 93 I'd like this move point
holding down the file and getting some
background guys yes yes bishop do you
want if Bishop takes c3 I think just
Queen takes c4 you don't have roots III
who do you want but if efficiency third
Queen c4 I mean just wanting a seaport
and then just take once you want yeah
that's perfect yeah yeah I think Jeffrey
is just winning here I think he's just
coming through you know with a solid
play I yeah I mean this is I think
Jeffrey's just winning a full piece now
yeah which puts them up a rug yes
terminate it's gonna make the score nice
yeah and look at how some of the windows
to in to make its nine in half not quite
okay yeah it was a scary there were a
few scary moments twice that halfway
point being levels don't still need half
a point we still need half a point I've
said before I think this these final
rounds are aware of the archbishop
really shined with the the head-to-head
matchups efficiency three I thought
Queen takes support you like Queen c4
it's really strong like some really
strong it make sure we're not missing
any tactics they Bishop before Queen
before Bishop 592 we even have rook
takes D - yeah thanks questions you want
is everything yeah
Jeffery though I like this taking his
time being sure making absolutely sure
that he sees everything
cuz once again there's takes on e5 to
the so is watching and commenting and
he's complimenting Jeffries opening
choice he says qga was a good choice and
then he says Scandinavian was awful Oh
of course just a half point to win the
match and sleep after half point looks
to miss going a full point to winning
positions all we need is a half a point
I think it'll be doable
so we need Caleb half a point we did see
a queen takes e5 from Lenny a and now
this e pawn is falling as well and
that's two extra pots it's just two
extra punts he's taking his time
yeah probably keeping an eye on
Jeffrey's game as well no I'm trying to
see okay don't slack yes like you're
plenty of time he does have a time edge
for the first time in the match I think
and just Queen takes d5 looks good
enough to me
Queen takes d5 rook a one to follow and
this a pawn will tell a story of the
game yeah yeah yes just liquidate the
Queens yeah and we do see Queen e5 from
money and it's tough actually to avoid
the Queen trade now who's gonna be
saying the RIP nb8 is under pressure and
so we do see the Queen's come off the
board and now rook b5 can we just play a
six well I guess no can we just play
rook a 1 no not in time so we have to
defend our pond so Knight c4 makes a lot
of sense
and now the rook attacks
can you consciously choose ce-5 I like
you yeah you five puts this pawn on a
defended square and trading the Knights
I think should be winning for white so
if the knight moves down Ricky for will
defend the night without putting white
and uncomfortable pen I don't think you
could have fed a little bit more cleanly
like earlier like good Knight takes e5
yeah I think it's e5 although I mean
match situation and draw is good enough
and this is not make this play breaking
news Geoffrey has won one his gastic
that brings us to eight and a half
points clear over the eight point
threshold we needed we will be going to
Oslo in the finals the whole team yes
congratulations Walmart and our Jewish
up yourself everybody all the fans and
all the players to finals now yes we are
going to also where both the semi-final
match and the final match are going to
be Jewish of course the players thus far
have just been playing online but they
will be face to face in Norway so we'll
see them actually still playing on chess
calm but with with monitors set up right
next to each other kind of in the
professional gaming kind of setup so
here we have rookie 40th this is just
taking a technically winning position
here and yeah f4 will solidify the e5
pawn and then two pawns extra you can
just play a six and start getting this
maybe even have four or five and e6 get
it get the past on rolling it passed
pawns on both sides of the board so he
was an ICC six yeah I think we can
simply play f4 here and then respond to
knight c6 with a six
then the rook is actually a little bit
stuck on on c5 so let me hang out just
playing for some extra points we have
officially won the match and we'll be
going to Oslo Norway for the finals as
we've been saying definitely you know a
strong match from the India Yogi's
though very good fight yes it's where it
all fell apart for me yeah just this
last round I don't know it just somehow
I'd be bummed making a quick draw and
then shock not not getting it done
either not a shock didn't have a very
good day yeah bad day for shock
yeah but Fabi I mean in the last turn in
puppy just never really gave him a
chance
yeah that's gonna happen sometimes black
against Fabiana Keira wanna you it's
tough to press Fabiano doesn't want to
push the card so we do see f4 knight c6
is the natural thank you but I think
there might be like a five eight shake
oh yeah hey six was my my move as well
okay now King f8 probably rook d4 makes
some sense but no the nice we're just
bringing up - okay Rick b5 relieves the
pressure on the night though so this
probably gives us some more options now
maybe I don't know if I want to play
east six so maybe f5 just like f5 g4 and
then start pushing okay Ricky - but now
after rook c5 are you coming out this
Ruby - now to trade but yeah rook c5 do
you just repeat or D play or exceed -
maybe
oh okay rook CQ I wonder 96 then we play
six yes
and then you're you're actually
threatening to play something like 93
and force the trade of the rooks yeah I
like Lucy - okay and it comes on the
board probably King g7 has to be played
just king g3 hey can you seven King III
get the King over and then eventually
okay so 96 but no this doesn't allow 93
I think nobody a six and and okay well
you know what the night of May 7 the
king can come through p3
okay there are many ways to win here 93
93 is one idea yeah 93 will work a 5 I
don't see why why we should allow this I
was thinking just to go night at 5 there
ok 6 and 7 with a 96
okay so 93 I guess after kingi through
there's work c62 to attack upon I'm 67
first and now I think that's not a 5
idea is coming through a 96 what is that
I cannot move there's a background mate
if you play Jew 696 h6 and you basically
have no moves I can't even play like h4
h5 for g4 96 is immediate I mean Rick p7
also trends a checkmate there's so many
ways to make sure and yeah it's kind of
instructive you see Lenny a not holding
on to the ape on for dear life instead
with this line he uses it as a decoy to
get the black pieces out of play and now
he's going to win on the Kings side so
what to do here maybe just 96 f6 is
forced but now Knight back to f5 is just
winning g7
maybe we just can't get cream yeah and
then pass deep on oh my goodness
he takes on okay so this is also winning
it takes the night then f7 check-in in
the nights we'll trade and now h6 is
following the the black king is getting
checkmated money hey down two seconds
again Oh flag don't flag money a go fast
faster Linney
oh my play moves okay alright get
nervous getting nervous
not that it matters Knight takes pawn
let's go menu takes the pawn to extra
pawns now the pressure on a seven-day
run f6 let's go three extra pawns and
maybe it's time to resign for for Hari
Krishna rook d7 a nice move boxing out
the Black Knight keeping an eye on all
those jumps and now h4 h5 h6 h7 we'll
get the job done
of course Lenny a just repeating gaining
some increment there and now all the
pawns come up there's push pushes f5
first
you know Rick t5 it's the night and I
don't know I heard her system playing
but well we'll stick it through to the
ends
Rick c5 and now g4 probably hang out for
even g4 whole rageful just get the pawns
up the board and this game and end the
suffering York b5
yeah no king of five Ricky five oh my
god oh boy
down the exchange now still totally
winning no buts it's a little silly
maybe it's a little silly
I think f7 was actually playable there
oh but no then uh yeah maybe you could
play off seven but there's there's a
trick with the skewer in the end Wow
just think how did krishna just doesn't
want to give up nine and a half killing
nine laughs my position cost my position
I was thinking ten six but nine and half
again congratulations yeah players
absolutely manager everybody
overall I think I do wanna mention the
archbishop's undefeated throughout the
regular season so continuing performance
in the last round
Geoffrey Sean coming through and
Domingues you know don't mean is
finished with two wins after that the
clock accident yeah so he came through
that we don't that beat
he beat two of their best players mama
Dee out of and Hari Krishna yes I do
want to say though I think once again
Wesley so is the core of this team he
has held it together throughout every
match and he did so today as well
scoring it yeah something like that
something fantastic and now Archbishop's
are in the finals and yes they may join
us once again for the semi finals in the
finals I don't know maybe we'll have
on-site coverage maybe we won't see but
definitely keep an eye on the
archbishop's we're hoping to win it all
this two more matches away from waiting
then yes that's all it takes
20:20 season undefeated so far hoping
hoping it will continue till the
well thank you all very much for joining
us here this has been Caleb Denby and
Grandmaster vara Kobe and giving you the
live coverage of the Archbishop's we
will be continuing on to the finals in
Norway and with that thank you very much
for watching Congrats again to the
players and we will see you next time
the st. Louis chess club hosts the 2020
US Championship and u.s. women's
championship April 8th through the 25th
these national championship events
feature 12 of the strongest chess
players in America competitors will
battle for a combined prize fund of
nearly $300,000 with qualification end
of the world championship cycle and the
coveted title of US Champion first round
of play begins April 10th at the st.
Louis chest-bump
watch live at the club or at us chess
champ Scott doorway the chess capital of
Europe mean Greek and Seibel with Magnus
Carlsen
it's the pro chess league finals at
chess party 2020 Caruana
so
boat s hammer Rudolph's chest bras an
open Fisher random chess tournament
[Music]
will you be part of the world's biggest
chest party
this has been a presentation of the st.
Louis chess club
you